hemos estado haciendo analogías entre la
multiplicación inusual que es la
multiplicación aritmética y la
multiplicación entre matrices y bueno la
primera analogía que hicimos fue con la
propiedad de identidad tenemos aquí al
número uno y si lo multiplicamos por
cualquier otro número nos queda pues ese
otro número y entonces decimos que este
número uno es el número identidad aunque
hay que tiene la propiedad de identidad
que es justo en esta propiedad y pues
recordando que esto pasa entre los
números entonces nosotros nos pusimos a
pensar si hay algo parecido en las
matrices y entonces empezamos a hablar
de matrices identidad que si los
multiplicamos por alguna otra matriz nos
queda justo esa otra matriz y
encontramos cuáles tienen que ser y cómo
tienen que ser y bueno seguramente
también te demostraste para ti mismo
y hay una matriz que si ponemos una la
matriz a por acá también tenemos una
matriz identidad por acá que si
multiplicamos a cualquier matriz por
esta matriz identidad nos queda la
matriz a que bueno en el caso en el que
la matriz a es una matriz cuadrada o sea
que tienen la misma cantidad de columnas
que de filas entonces estas dos matrices
identidad son la misma sin embargo así
esta matriz no es una matriz cuadrada y
no tiene el mismo número de filas que de
columnas entonces estas dos matrices
tienen la misma estructura que es puros
unos en la diagonal y puros ceros en el
resto de las entradas pero van a ser de
una dimensión distinta en fin siguiendo
con esto de las analogías entre la
multiplicación de números y la
multiplicación de matrices hay otro
número que es súper importante a ver si
tenemos cualquier número y lo
multiplicamos por el cero pues nos queda
cero
y bueno de la misma forma si tomamos el
0 y lo multiplicamos por cualquier otro
número nos queda el mismo 0 entonces
vamos a ver lo análogo pero con la
multiplicación de matrices lo análogo a
esto pero para la multiplicación en
primer tristes pues es muy parecido a lo
que tenemos aquí o sea busquemos una
matriz que no importa lo que pongamos
aquí si las multiplicamos nos queda esta
misma matriz y de la misma forma del
otro lado o sea si tenemos por aquí esta
matriz especial no importa por qué
matriz la multiplicamos nos quede esta
matriz especial y bueno como está
tomando la propiedad del 0 en los
números pues le vamos a llamar la matriz
0 así es que se trata de una matriz
pero que si la multiplicamos por
cualquier otra cosa nos queda una matriz
0 aunque bueno esta matriz no
necesariamente va a ser exactamente
igual a ésta definitivamente las dos van
a ser matrices 0 pero sus dimensiones no
necesariamente van a ser iguales si la
matriz a no es una matriz cuadrada o sea
no tiene el mismo número de columnas que
de files entonces estas dos matrices van
a tener dimensiones distintas y bueno la
verdad me imagino que tienes una muy
buena idea de cómo son las matrices 0 a
ver veamos un ejemplo digamos que
tenemos por aquí a la matriz a igual a
4 entonces la matriz de ceros tendría
que ser pues podemos simplemente poner
ceros aquí no
entonces esto lo que nos quedaría
es haber hacemos el producto punto de
este vector 00 por 13 y nos queda 0 por
1 mes 0 por 3 que es un cero aunque y lo
mismo pasa para el resto de estas
entradas ok porque todas las entradas
son cero entonces esta matriz cero por a
es otra vez la matriz cero bueno a ver
vamos a ver otro ejemplo 1 2 3 4 5 6
y entonces la matriz 0
pues mira esta matriz tiene dos filas
entonces para que funcione la
multiplicación entre estas dos matrices
esta matriz tiene que tener dos columnas
y pues le vamos a poner puros ceros pero
esta matriz puede tener todas las filas
que a mí se me ocurran
ok entonces voy a ponerle tres filas de
ceros y bueno aquí te voy a proponer que
pongas una pausa y averigües cuál es la
multiplicación de estas dos matrices
pues lo primero que hay que hacer es ver
qué dimensión tiene esta es una matriz
de 3 por 2 y esta es una matriz de 2 x 3
ahora como el número de columnas de esta
matriz y el número de filas de esta
matriz son iguales entonces si está bien
que estamos multiplicando estas dos
matrices y también sabemos que la
multiplicación de estas dos matrices
base
una matriz que tiene esta cantidad de
filas
y esta cantidad de columnas entonces es
una matriz de tres por tres y bueno la
verdad voy a dejar que tú hagas las
cuentas pero se puede ver claramente que
todas las entradas de esta matriz van a
ser puros ceros
cierto porque cada que tomemos una
columna de aquí y la multiplicamos por
alguna de estas filas nos va a quedar 0
entonces tomamos una matriz que no era
cuadrada que no tenía la misma cantidad
de filas que de columnas y la
multiplicamos por una matriz 0 y lo que
obtuvimos fue otra matriz 0 pero con una
dimensión distinta a la matriz 0 con la
que empezamos